thought process was that we had
personally introduced cholera to the
earthquake zone so that we could make
money because we were rocking in our
four by fours and one and a half million
people were still homeless
[Music]
so
we always start with the trigger warning
before any of my talks
because I have worked as a midwife in
war zones and refugee camps and posts
disaster including earthquakes and color
epidemics
and the topic is horrid right you know I
wouldn't be telling you the truth if I
wasn't giving you the the real
experience but that does come with a
warning of maternal loss baby loss
maternal injury birth injuries and if
that's not your stuff it's all right if
you want to leave at any point it's all
right because one of the things I was
really careful about before writing my
book is the last thing I would want is
me telling my story then ending up
harming somebody else so there is a
trigger warning
and now for the story is I'm going to
take you back this is a story that
starts in the 80s with anybody with
young kids that is a Bluey reference but
I'm not getting anything back from the
faces
um so I want to picture the eighties and
I'm six years old and when you're six
you think life is good right you think
good win's over evil you think you're
like little Nintendo games are the best
things on Earth you go cycling without
telling your parents where you're going
to because it's the eighties and you
play Kiss Chase in the park and life is
pretty good and then also in the 80s we
sat down one Saturday evening we
probably had a Chinese Takeaway you know
what Chinese takeaways in the 80s are
like very red very gooey MSG
and as a family we thought you know what
a good idea is let's sit down and watch
live Aid so we sat down and it was the
first time that ever on TV after the BBC
news that starvation camps had been
shown on British television which
shocked us you know as it should do
in a world where we create more food
than we can possibly eat and about a
third of it is put in landfill sites it
is completely inconceivable that people
are dying on starvation and that should
shock us right we should still be
shocked about this but me as a
six-year-old I completely invested in
the story that Live Aid sold us was that
you can make a difference if you give us
five pounds if you give us 10 pounds you
can actually make a difference to this
seemingly reasonably simplistic thing
that people don't have enough food so
let's give them food and I am
embarrassed to say it but I fully
invested in my heart I thought you know
I'm not going to give them five pounds
I'm not going to give them 10 pounds I'm
going to be a nurse as much as a
six-year-old can plan their future and
I'm going to do something helpful
um and and that feeling never left the
next time there was a tsunami the next
time there was an earthquake the next
time our screens were filled with
disaster it felt grotesque to be sitting
in this very affluent house with my very
happy family
um completely I put my hands up a
background of privilege in that I had
peace and love and security
and it felt awful just to watch it
vicariously on the TV and maybe give
five pounds maybe give 10 pounds so
every time I saw it that feeling was
consolidated
I trained in the NHS to be a nurse I was
an AE nurse for three years
unfortunately because of a close family
friend that was raped and murdered in a
very public scenario I then specialized
in rape care and sexual violence
survivors within a e
I traveled and worked in Zambia I
qualified in tropical medicine and I
felt like I was putting like all these
tools in my tool belt because then
finally once I add up all the tools in
my tool belt I'm gonna be able to go to
This Disaster and I'm going to be so
helpful oh my God those starving
children like I'm embarrassed admitting
it but I just thought you know I'm gonna
make this positive difference
when you go into Aid work there's lots
of different organizations you can work
for so I'm just doing a slight little
pitch for medicines on Frontier msf.to
that borders because when I met with
them they completely represented my own
personal views basic Healthcare should
be given regardless of race gender
politics sexual orientation your
geography who your politicians are who's
in government we all agree I'm sure as a
baseline that Healthcare should be given
irrespective of all those and msf
currently Works in 70 countries
worldwide providing Healthcare
regardless of all these things so I was
like yeah I'm signing up for msf I went
to my training course in Germany where
we got kidnapped at midnight in a frozen
Forest by somebody the smell of alcohol
and spoke a different language and held
a good pretend gun to me so I got to
play out all the training again another
thing in my toolbell I did the training
got the T-shirt get on and then go to
Amsterdam with my msf logo feeling
pretty cool unfortunately
and I fly to a war zone so my first
mission was for a year in South Sudan
which at that point was a country that
had experienced over 50 years of Civil
War
I was going to be leading one Healthcare
unit it was the only healthcare provider
in an area the size of Belgium
and it was going to be me and one of the
nurse informed huts and that was going
to be it but when you're in the UK and
your 26 year old altruistic
saving Angel
um yeah I was like yeah I can do that
why not so I get on the plane in Kenya
we fly into South Sudan and already you
know the plains like an old World War II
cargo plane and some of the nuts are
coming out and the leather seats are a
bit torn and there's no seat belt on it
and I'm looking out the window of these
porthole windows and everywhere you
looked in all directions it was just
completely flat and in one hour's flight
we estimated that we flew over ten
thousand land mines who was in the land
there were no trees there were no Rivers
there was no life as we could see
because life in South Sudan because it
is so hot 50 degrees Centigrade on the
Dolby landed that life is really tough
and the plane lands and everybody gets
off and we've landed in a place called
lankien and we take off all the aid
boxes and then everybody knows what
they're doing everybody except me and
I'm sat there thinking I feel slightly
out of my depth
and that was when my first patient Got
Loaded into the plane so she was brought
in on a stretcher made of sticks and for
dignity she was covered with a sheet
but what hit me first was her smell
and what this woman had experienced was
two years before she'd been pregnant and
no access to a midwife because the war
had taken it from her she had no access
to a hospital because the war had taken
it from her
very very sadly for her her baby had
died inside her
but then that wasn't the worst thing to
happen to her
the baby then didn't deliver
and over the next six months the dead
baby had slowly eroded its way out of
her body which created a hole into her
bladder and a hole into a bowel
she then constantly leaked everything
that we would pass into the toilet
vaginally and the smell was Unstoppable
that wasn't the end of her suffering
because then the smell meant that she
was kicked out from her family home and
for two years she'd been homeless
experience
was just like
a massive wake-up call for me and to
even talk about my experience whilst her
suffering is clearly the worst I very
much recommend that I am still speaking
from a privileged position but it really
was my wake-up call of War zones aren't
fun right you can't just fly in with
your toolkit and think you can save the
day how ridiculous is that and it took
actually being in a war zone to
recognize it
and then the plane landed and thank
goodness that the msf team swooped in
and they took her off to the surgical
hospital
and like this ambulance to the 4x4 left
like in this trail of dust and I was
left thinking like what what am I what
am I doing here
the plane then took me onto my product
which was in Tam which is this area that
was particularly unstable because it's
before Sudan and South Sudan were
separated and there was a lot of troop
movements everybody carried an AK-47 and
out of the mud dust as the plane land
landed James my nursing partner who was
a 62 year old American Buddhist
he had been a Hell's Angel he had been
born to a mother who was addicted to
heroin he'd spent the first 40 Years of
his life being alcoholic even when he
was an intensive care nurse he then
crashed his motorbike cracked his skull
in four places and realized he had life
or death ahead of him and he chose life
and became a Zen Buddhist
over time I have learned that James is
one of the most magical brilliant
wonderful persons on Earth but if I'm
honest as he stepped out the desk he's
got a handlebar mustache completely
shaved head he's got biker tattoos
and he very happily like met me telling
me he used to be in prison so really
this isn't quite as bad as being prison
for dealing drugs in Mexico I just
thought what is msf like put me with
with this ex-convict X Angel bike you
know biker guy
what I realized from James was which I
hadn't learned in my very lovely house
growing up is there is a real power of
just speaking your truth
which I know sounds really corny I know
it does I know it makes us all cringe
but he had no holes barred at all he had
no filter No Boundaries it's a very
British me was like oh who is this guy
but actually the next time a kid came
with a snake bite the next time somebody
came with a landmine um injury the next
time a woman came who was having
triplets and we had no other access to
healthcare and I was going to be the
only person providing her with care
he had this way of just breathing in
and he say equanimity
which annoyed me at the time and we
would get on with the activity
over time in South Sudan we would see
about a thousand patients a month who
had no other access to health care we
could get a flight into us for surgical
procedures and to fly somebody out for a
cesarean section but I knew that cost
the charity at least ten thousand pounds
and when it rained because the runway
was literally just mud there was no way
of getting a flight in
clearly we weren't able to save every
single life that came to us
I really thought we were going to I
really did I really thought I'm working
with msf we can save the world I really
thought I could
and what happened over time for the year
being there is I got better I got better
at deliveries I got better at snake
bites I got better at burying this
feeling of I'm completely out of control
and really having a bad time about this
and I came back to the UK and you know
my auntie went oh how's your Gap year
and you just like I don't know I could
you know how long have you got today I
could speak for half an hour I could
speak for the next 14 years and I
probably wouldn't be finished
and I had no language of processing that
at that time what I perceived was that I
had failed people I can still name Yuan
nuwac newbol Eve Grace Mary baby Mary
they sit with me on my shoulder and over
the years I have learned to process them
but I cannot name how long was I there
for a year so statistically I cannot
name us twelve thousand people that we
did give access to healthcare for but I
can name every single person that we
didn't
my perception of that was I need to
learn more I need to do more I'm going
to learn more next time I'm going to be
the best Midwife so I came back to the
UK and trained as a midwife and I got a
good grade
and then straight away rather than
consolidating I went to Haiti after the
earthquake in 2010.
um when we arrived in Haiti there had
been a complete political collapse it
was gang Warfare and humanitarian Aid
workers were perceived as being
the thought process was that we had
perfectly introduced cholera to the
earthquake zone so that we could make
money because we were rocking in our
four by fours and one and a half million
people were still homeless you know 10
months after the earthquake and it was
quite dangerous there was quite a high
risk of kidnapping and hijacking because
we had money and a lot of people were
completely desperate
um in this space we tried to set up one
color Treatment Center in a place called
La Celine and
um it would be a little bit like picture
where you live now
and imagine if some Aid workers who
speak a different language to you came
up and knocked on your door and said
this really infectious disease that is
passed really quickly between people we
want to treat about 30 000 of them just
outside is that all right and people
said no because you know you wouldn't
want people coming to your neighborhood
with something that's really infectious
um so we understood it but we got kicked
out of one site and then we did manage
to set up another treatment center in
Carrefour where I then specialized in
childbirth in cholera so just very
basically if you have cholera you lose
60 liters of diarrhea very quickly which
kills you after about six liters but
imagine on top of that you've got the
watery diarrhea but you're also giving
birth
so just logistically like it's it's
crazy so what we ended up doing is
because there's no guidance there wasn't
at the time for maternity care in choler
epidemics
um it ended up being a sheet so I would
have two helpers that would literally
hold a sheet at the point of the
perineum so the Poo would go down and
the baby would come up and that was the
best that we could manage at the time
good news is we uh cholera has got over
50 Cent death rate that's not the good
news
um with treatment cholera's got a 99
survival rate and we saw 3 000 people
per month and we had a 99 survival rate
and we didn't lose any moms or babies
and we even had breastfeeding within the
collar Treatment Center
um done safely and healthy so there was
huge successes
but I came back from Haiti and I was
thinking it's not you know I haven't
done enough yet I still haven't you know
made this difference that this
six-year-old me had imagined that I was
going to be able to and so I had a week
at home and then I went to Bangladesh
for another year
um in Bangladesh I was working as a
midwife in a refugee camp for rohingya
stateless people who had fled Myanmar
and come to Bangladesh they were
stateless Myanmar didn't want them but
Bangladesh also didn't want them as much
as if 30 000 people were to arrive on
the south coast on boats maybe we
weren't particularly welcome them into
the UK either so we can have compassion
with the system that is already
stretched that is not accepting refugees
because we do it ourselves at times
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below or visit iai.tv for
more debates and talks from the world's
leading thinkers on today's biggest
ideas